hi I'm Eric Singer and back and today I
want to talk about some interesting
similarities between different unrelated
accents in the english-speaking world
south we can define a vowel sound
according to two pretty basic things one
is what the lips are doing whether
they're rounding forwards or not and the
other is where the tongue is in the
mouth and to pinpoint that B as a map
we call it the vowel space looks like
this it's a quadrilateral the front of
the mouth it's basically a person facing
to the left like this or in a
cross-section the front of the mouth is
over here Mac and mouth is over here so
let's talk about a feature I've talked a
lot about before goose fronting goose
fronting goose front and goose fronting
what is that exactly
I've said it means the goose vowel is
pronounced further forward in the mouth
but what does that mean so if the tongue
is up like this somewhere up in this
area and the lips are rounded forwards
we have an O sound you can probably feel
that make an O sound like a
nineteenth-century Shakespearean actor
or a 1950's no coward character saying
u2 and breathe in some cold air over
that tongue you might be able to feel
that it's arched up high in the back
right up here now if that arch of the
tongue moves forwards and you get
something that's arched up high but
closer to the front of the mouth
something like E then you've got goose
fronting and we can find this goose
fronting in a lot of different places in
the world you hear goose fronting in
Australia goose in London goose in
Ireland goose you hear it in the
southern US a lot you can hear it in
California accents goose and here for
your viewing and listening pleasure
a goose fronting medley goose goose
goose goose goose goose
now let's talk about something called
mouth raising this is a feature that we
might find in Australian accents
now London accents mouth New York
accents now a lot of southern accents
now mouth in my own accent starts down
here something like ah and moves up here
and runs the lips a little bit something
like oh oh and you might be able to feel
that in your own mouth
if you imitate my mouth bow mouth
raising then would raise the starting
point so instead of being down around
here a little bit higher and gonna go
something like ah I'm not sure exactly
which accent that was they're all
roughly similar not exactly the same
sound but they're all gonna start that
mouth though from a little bit higher up
here's a London version south here's a
New York version so here's an Australian
version south
here's a u.s. southern version and here
they are all up against each other south
south south so in the kit set of words
words like ship and women and bid and
missed we have a phenomenon in New
Zealand where the vowel sound instead of
being towards the front and pretty high
something like an e it's gonna move back
towards the center back towards the
schwa this sound and that's why we had
fish and chips as a way you might be
able to tell an Australian from a New
Zealand er fish and chips fish and chips
in South Africa we have something very
similar we have kits entering as well
the trick is it only happens on some of
those kit words milk myth it's a little
complicated but if you follow that kit
vowel with a gut or a cup hard G or a K
sound that takes you're gonna keep it
from centering it's gonna keep it up so
you get big or kick baked cake in other
words we don't have one of those sounds
following it will also be centered like
New Zealand so but cooked that's that's
fish and chips chips so that's a weird
totally coincidental similarity between
those two accents
let's talk about a really similar start
vowel in Boston accents and in Irish
accent stop trust in their higher
seharris instead of a start bell like
mine that might be very much towards the
back of the mouth ah I was followed by
an R but it starts back here ah sort of
low cupped area we're gonna have
something that's much more fronted we
could call it start fronting so we'll
have a Boston accent that doesn't have
that R sound it's kind of just a vowel
at the front stab here's Boston speakers
stat Wow in a very pronounced
Irish accent we're gonna get a really
clear version of that exact same vowel
sound
we are gonna hear it with an R after it
but the vowel sound is still this front
at stash here's one of those trusts in
their hearts our hearts stop so
hopefully now you know what the hell I'm
talking about when I use terms like
higher lower fronted back centered it's
a map
[Music]